A widely used symmetric
encryption scheme
is based on the data
encryption standard, or DES.
It was published in 1977 and
standardized in 1979.
In DES the key is 64 bit,
which is 8 bites but for
each bite, there's one parity bit.
Therefore, the actual value
in the key is only 56-bit.
And the oppo cipher text
is again a 64-bit block.
Here's a high level view of DES.
There are 16 rounds of operations.
>From the origin of 56-bit key,
16 subkeys are generated.
One for each round.
The process of decryption with DES,
is essentially the same as
the encryption process.
It works as follows.
Use the cipher text as input to this.
But then, for sub keys,
they use in reverse order.
That is use key 16 at
the first round of decryption.
Use key 15in the second
round of decryption.
And so and so forth.
That is for decryption,
we run the same algorithm.
But only the keys in reverse order.
We call that diffusion is one of
the principles in encryption and
it is typically achieved
through permutation.
In DES, permutation works by
changing the positions of the bits.
Recall that DES has 16
rounds of operations.
Each DES round has the same operations
and uses a different per round key.
Each DES round takes as input the server
text produced by the previous round.
And outputs text for the next round.
The input is divided into
the left half and the right half.
The output left half is just
the right half of the input.
The right half of the output is a result
of the left half of the input and
the output of the function.
The mangler function takes this input,
the 32 bit input right half,
expands it to 48 bit,
then with the 48 bit program key.
Then use the s-boxes to substitute
the 48 bit value into a 32 bit value.
We can also use algebra to
represent your in a death round.
That is, the left half of output
is the right half of the input.
And the right half of the input is
the result of the left half of input.
And the result of a mangler function,
which takes as input the right half
of the input and the [INAUDIBLE] key.